bienvenue à paroles autochtone 6000 sa
mort lundi puis cette semaine j'ai reçu
une question de france et que d'ailleurs
on va l'écouter
est ce que cette minorité d'amérindiens
qui aimerait que le québec se sépare
alors franssens me demande si les
autochtones en général sont pour la
souveraineté du québec
je dirais que ça dépend comment tu
définis la souveraineté pour les
premières nations et pour les québécois
si on parle d'une souveraineté qui est
plus classique comme ça qu'on a connu
jusqu'à maintenant les deux derniers
référendum qui veut dire que les
québécois le québec se sépare du canada
ou si tu le penses tout dans une
définition qui est votre plus proche des
programmations c'est dire que le québec
veut se séparer du canada mais les
progrès sont venus se séparer du québec
et peut-être même dès faut garder des
relations avec le canada
parce que justement nominations ne sont
pas séparés uniquement par des lignes
provincial mais ce sont des territoires
qui sont plus à l'horizontale donc on va
voir le territoire allemand aucun qui
connecte avec l'ontario les territoires
nous qui connecte avec le labrador alors
tu peux imaginer que la souveraineté
pour nous a pas la même définition
d'ailleurs je pense que c'est souvent la
discussion qui ont manqué énormément à
la souveraineté à la question de
souveraineté la discussion avec les
programmations sur ce que vous le dire
la souveraineté ce que ça impliquait
pour les premières nations
malheureusement quand j'ai eu des fois
des discussions qu exane et sur la
souveraineté et dont on va faire la
souveraineté puis après ça on va parler
que les premières nations
on se dit qu'on pense pas qu'on va la
faire comme ça cette fois ci donc c'est
certain qu'il ya des gens qui vont
vouloir faire la souveraineté parce
qu'on voit quand même l'esprit
communauté comme étant une forme de
séparation du reste de la province
mais je pense que dans la souveraineté
québécoise telle qu'elle est et
réfléchissent à dire sans les premières
nations
ce sera pas possible mais c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que beaucoup de gens
ont commencé à entamer la discussion
avec les programmations pour d'autres
c'est quoi la souveraineté pour vous
comment est-ce qu'on pourrait
l'organiser en québécois et premières
nations et ces discussions ne doit avoir
lieu je pense avant de vouloir aller
faire cette souveraineté
donc j'espère fascine que ça ça peut
avoir répondu à la question que j'ai
puis il ya un peu plus de à ton moulin
et j'espère que vous y serez pas à nous
envoyer des questions un espace
autochtone bonne semaine